[Music]
at first glance Riverdale might seem
like a basic highschool drama
however if you give this TV series a
chance you'll see that it's anything but
basic this unpredictable show will leave
you speechless and so will the following
fan theories watch until the end to find
out which Riverdale couple might not
make it to season 4 new here subscribe
to the things and hit that notification
bell to be the first in line to catch
our latest videos don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up if you love
river del now let's check out some of
these theories shall we
there's another secret blossom and it's
Jughead Jones if you think the Cooper
and the blossom family tree isn't
complicated enough as it is wait until
you hear this span theory by now we
already know that how Cooper and
Clifford blossom are estranged second
cousins this connection came delight
after Polly became pregnant with the
late Jason blossom who just so happened
to be her third cousin talking about
gross anyways this wasn't Polly's fault
since it was her father who kept their
lineage hidden after all now that this
family secret has come to life fans are
wondering if there's more to the Cooper
family tree than meets the eye you
guessed it the next person of interest
is Jughead Jones Betty's mother Alice
Cooper has it passed with jugheads
father FP however the extent of their
relationship has yet to be proven
fantastic the theory that FP who covered
up Jason's murder kept his letterman
jacket for a reason well this may sound
far-fetched you have to admit that FP
isn't a sentimental guy so why keep
Jason's jacket while the thought of
Jughead and Betty being related is
enough to make us sick the same thing
happened to Jason and Polly so why not
them chic is very much alive moving on
we all know that chic isn't he he's been
pretending to be while many of us
speculated that sheep with evil or
guilty of something big
we never thought he wasn't Alice's
biological son well surprise surprise
she is an imposter so what happened to
the real Charles
according to chic Charles overdosed on
jingle-jingle before Alice and Betty
adver came looking for him a date on
jingle-jangle
now she might have lied about who he was
but did this warrant Betty's choice to
hand him over to the black hood
probably not while we last saw Sheik
trying to outrun the black hood none of
us saw him take his last breaths so by
default he could still be running around
Riverdale causing mayhem right a popular
fan theory is that how has other plans
for Sheik after all how never confessed
to killing Sheik despite everything she
quit the Cooper's threw Betty served him
a twisted hand and surely he might come
back to even out the score for your
Sheik series let us know if you think
he's alive and well or Six Feet Under
in the comments Charles is alive and he
goes by the name of vent with so many
river dolphin theories out there it can
be hard to separate the possible from
the impossible if there's one theory
that makes perfect sense it's the
following one so chic isn't chic and
Charles is proclaimed as dead but hey
this sounds too good to be true right so
what if Charles has been staring us
right in the face all along and we've
been too blind to notice him does the
name Ben ring a bell if not it's
probably because Riverdale did its best
to conceal his identity
all while plastering his face on screen
every now and then Finn was first
mentioned as being one of the mists
Grundy's underaged conquests but he soon
resurfaced when he served Kevin Keller
at the drive-in with the biggest clue of
all his when chic invited Ben into the
Cooper house claiming that he was his
friend by now we all know that Sheik
swings the other way so could he
possibly be in love with Ben and is
simply trying to help him get revenge on
the Cooper's this would make sense
especially since Kevin's gaydar seemed
to sound an alarm when he laid eyes on
Ben there are two black hoods and how
secret twin is one of them anyone
following the Riverdale series believes
there to be two black hoods this makes
sense after all especially since how had
an alibi during the time of Fred Andrews
shooting oh not to mention that Howells
eyes aren't the ones we saw behind the
mask if this had been the case Archie
would have recognized them right away
Archie and Betty grew up side by side so
how would it be possible for him not to
recognise her own father point blank
it just isn't this has led many fans to
believe that the blosum curse lived on
and more than just one person the fact
that twins run in the blosum family
shouldn't be overlooked
plus her blossom teams this genetic
trend could definitely apply to how but
then why keep his twin brother
seeker for his entire life who knows but
maybe it's the same reason how kept his
blossom blood a secret - at the end of
the day how seems to be full of
surprises however it's pretty obvious
that he isn't the brains of the
operation
while this fan Theory makes a lot of
sense we can't help but feel as though
it's just too obvious Riverdale has a
knack for surprising his viewers so why
take a shortcut like this the truth
remains to be seen and will surely
surface during Riverdale's third season
Alice will join a major cult it's a
mother's worst nightmare to find out her
child isn't doing too well so imagine
how Alice Cooper felt when she confessed
to Charles being dead while she may
never have met her biological son that
doesn't mean she didn't love him from
afar Alice might not have the best track
record when it comes to her children but
she always shows up when they need her
this was clearly demonstrated when she
covered up cheeks murder granted she
still believed him to be her son at this
point when she confessed to Charles
having overdosed on jingle-jangle
something in Alice visibly broke it
isn't too unrealistic to believe that
she feels guilty for Charles death
especially since she gave him up for
adoption now let's get to the point it's
pretty obvious that Polly is in some
sort of cult it's also obvious that
she's been trying to recruit her mother
has Alice's remorseful state turned her
into a good candidate for Polly's cult
you guys will just have to wait around
and see regardless of whether she
chooses to join it or not a cult seems
to be headed River Delta way whether the
town knows it or not
penny Peabody is Betty's real mother
while this might be a strange River
Dolphin theory it isn't the weirdest one
we've encountered so far do you remember
penny Peabody right she's the serpent
lawyer who conned a Jughead into making
some very illegal deliveries while she
may no longer be welcome on serpent
territory it's quite obvious that she
has it out for Jughead and FP
/ first some fans believe that penny and
Alice Cooper are actually related and
that there's a ton of hidden history
between them this could be possible
after all both Alice and Penny are blind
women who were raised on the south side
fans are speculating that penny got
pregnant and feared for her unborn
daughter's life Alice who was mourning
her choice to give up her son offered to
adopt Betty
Allison raised her as her own daughter
although she may very well be her niece
or distant cousin this information makes
sense depending on how you choose to
view it could it be possible that
Alice's past is even messier than we
could ever imagine if this theory seems
too shocking to be true wait until you
hear number 1 Hiram is working with a
black hood it goes without saying that
Hiram Lodge is up to no good his plans
to cause rifts between the Riverdale
social groups are undeniable for how far
is he really willing to go he's already
put the lives of his daughter and wife
in danger but luckily these two ladies
can take good care of themselves the
fact that the black hood attacked Fred
Andrews on the basis of adultery hits a
little too close to home fans believe
that the green eyed black hood doesn't
have anything to do with the real black
hood instead he's just a guy Hyrum hired
to cure Fred after all Fred did get a
little too chummy with his wife for
Miami while Hiram was in jail whether
this is true or not you can't deny that
Hiram has it out for the Andrew boys
sure he might have seemed like he was
warming up to Archie but he never took
an oath to protect him from harm's way
his daughter might have a soft spot for
him but Hiram never will for the time
being it appears that Archie is paying
for his father sins but Hiram really
stupid slow or was it just a pleasant
surprise that the black hood had it out
for Fred Andrews something smells a
little fishy here Archie is going to
make his bones with Hiram Archie might
love his father but he's made it clear
that obtaining Hiram's approval is also
super important to him this all changed
once
Archie began to notice just how corrupt
Hyrum really was Archie's Alliance
quickly shifted when he found out that
Hiram had hired tallboy to kill his
father while impersonating the black
hood instead of cutting contact and
letting sleeping dogs lie Durell
archiekins proceeded to threaten Hyrum
in his own study and when I do
I'm just gonna come for you it's safe to
say that Hiram didn't take these threats
lightly before long Archie was
wrongfully arrested for Cassidy's murder
and we all know who framed him season
two seemed to be ending on a high note
especially with Archie winning class
president unfortunately it ended with
him being carried away in handcuffs
instead
Archie promised Hiram that he'd make his
bones with him and fans believed that
this might happen in season three while
a showdown between these two characters
would be welcomed killing his
girlfriend's father is a major nono
Archie might not seem like a killer but
hey prison has been said to change
people for the worst what do you think
is Archie all bark and no bite
Archie and Veronica will break up young
love is a beautiful thing however it
doesn't really tend to last despite the
fact that Archie and Veronica
love each other dearly they do have some
bigger issues at hand
for starters Veronica's father just
framed Archie for a murder he didn't
commit
on top of that Archie and Veronica are
about to spend a lot of time apart which
is only normal when someone goes to jail
one of the latest fan theory states that
V and archiekins just won't be able to
hold the fort down with everything going
on in Riverdale Veronica just might
start developing feelings for someone
else we've seen couples like Betty and
Jughead go through some hard times but
Archie seems to be as strong as ever
will their love outlasts than many
obstacles in their path or will they
become a thing of the past
Mindy fans are beginning to notice the
similarities between Archie and his
father's generation and if history is
truly fated to repeat itself Archie and
Veronica might just have to call it
quits no one wants this amazing duo to
split up but sometimes things don't work
out like we want them to who's your
favorite Riverdale couple barchi or
Buckhead claudius blossom is actually
Clifford
if there's one Riverdale character who
has seriously been underestimated from
the beginning it's Clifford blossom many
of us were shocked when it was announced
that Clifford was behind his son Jason's
murder as a matter of fact even his own
daughter Cheryl was dumbfounded by the
news not only did Clifford murder his
only son but he also ran a secret drug
organization in Riverdale so much for
selling maple syrup rights when the cat
got out of the bag and arrests were
about to be made Clifford took his own
life now flash forward to season two and
here enters Claudius blossom Clifford's
identical twin brother I mean
claudius twin to your father Riverdale
fans know better the theory is that
Clifford found his own twin and killed
him in order to escape the hands of the
law but then went into hiding and kept a
low profile until it was time to pick up
where he left off while the scheme is
conniving and evil we wouldn't put it
past a Bloxom to act this way do you
have any of riverdale theories of your
own make sure to leave them in the
comments who knows you might be right on
the money and that sums up our 10
Riverdale season 3 theories thanks for
watching and stay tuned more great
content is on its way see you next time
[Music]